Got to tell him, man. I mean,
if you watch his fight with Glover to
sharer are you watch his fight with the
Little Nog? Yeah. That mother fucker's
of destroyer. He does. He's a destroyer.
We don't want to be,
we don't want to be in front of them.
And that shows you how
fucking tough DC is. Yeah.
That guy twice I throwed everything.
I had him, everything I had, I,
I need him in the face. Uh, kicked
him in his body. Sometimes I hit him.
I say like goes like this. I mean he
just, he just put, he just kept going.
DC's an animal, a four wheel
drive, just kept on going on,
whatever. And he just,
same pay. Same Pace. Yeah.
If I fired them again, I will, I
will. I will not stand in this book.
I want to stand in front of him.
So you think that was the critical error
right in front of 100% reach advantage?
Yeah. I respect that.
He's wrestling too much.
So yeah, if I found them again, I
would do it a way different way. Yeah.
I'm sure he'd do something different
too though. Right? He probably do.
You probably do, but it's still do one
thing and call it like, oh all the time.
Just keeps moving forward.
That's what it does.
That's what you gotta do
is you've got to catch him.
When he's coming down from a heavyweight,
he says you've ever the towel.
Like it's pushing down on it. It's
so awesome. I saw that. I saw that.
I want him to come down. I hope it's
coming down. He can't, he can't just like,
you know, take that fight. Now he
know. Even if he wins, he has to come,
come down and defend and fights
and if he beats deep bay,
he might freak Francis again.
Who knows?
You might fight Volkov who you know who
could fight? No, he has to fight me.
It doesn't want to fight me, but it has
to fight me. He has to in your mind,
he has to fight. That's what I need.
Yeah, that's mine. It's him or John.
So John's first. You would like
to be the first guy to fight John.
I welcome coming back right away.
Yeah, I mean, I mean, I'm trying,
I'm in camp and I'm not in camp. Sorry.
I'm training right. A feeling great.
My shoulder's good.
And I'm just waiting for an opportunity.
The light heavyweight is
pretty wide open right now,
particularly with this decision for DC
to fight against day. So we, you have,
you know, it's interesting
like you have, um,
owes Demir who just lost, right? You got
your friend Jimmy Manwell, you have a,
a few guys who are at the top
of the heap, you know, uh,
but you're the standout right now,
John being in the limbo.
Yeah. He's gone. Nobody knows
what's happening with him.
Stands out to you in that
division. Ilir Yeah, yeah,
yeah. You know, I want him
to find my teammates radical.
I don't find my teammates really,
I've been touring with him since I was,
I started my career. So do you meet
Jimmy? And the other is, you know,
we've been saying to each
other that whatever happens,
we're not fighting each other,
you know. Um, but, uh, yeah, the,
the only, the only the only five that
makes sense for me right now. It's a,
it's fighting, fighting the top guys
in our rank number one right now.
So I can't look back. I can look
down. I have to look up what, what's,
what's the next up here and uh,
if you take it from there,
we take it from there. And, and uh, like
you said with John Jones, he's in limbo.
I hope it comes back.
If it doesn't come back,
maybe I'll fight him in boxing.
I fight him in boxing too.
Why does he want to box?
He's been boxing Lenny's Instagram.
There's all they do is box now.
Right now we're really, yeah.
I haven't paid attention to his Instagram.
He's boxing all the time. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't see you see him coming back
as a boxer though. Mcgregor money.
We could. We could, yeah,
that's, that's another thing.
But we can think of like maybe a side
show here. We can box or whatever.
You just want to get in there with
them somehow or another that somehow,
somehow or another your competitive
drive once you get in there with them.
That was my, that's my,
like I told you, it's, it's,
it's bigger than winning the belt. That's
your Mount Everest, John Joan. It is.
John's out there going,
yeah, he knows that.
He knows that he is,
but he's still got that corvette.
Yo sell that thing. Get a minivan. Drive
slow. It looks good. Man. Looks real good.
Yeah,
you do.
It's gotta be so frustrating for him to
be in a situation that he's in. Yeah.
I can't even imagine. Yeah, I can
imagine either. It's, it's fucked up.
It's a crazy situation to be in.